Okay.
Coming to you by three.
Welcome everybody to the h three
podcast,
Tuesday edition.
Otherwise known as holy and lighten.
Correct.
Opinion Zone.
You plan on disagreeing with me or
arguing with me?
God is not an option.
I'll close it because I do want you all
watching the numbers are important,
but just know before warrant you are
wrong because this is the correct
opinion zone.
Today's episode is sponsored by 23 and
me,
quip and seat Geek.
Guess what's going down a week from
today,
Bill Burr,
the living legend,
the Titan of comedy,
one of the greatest comedians of all
time.
Is it going to sit right where Isla is
right now?
Okay,
I'm fucking terrified.
Bill bird is going to be here on
Tuesday.
Also important to note is that today is
young shredders a birthday.
He turned one years old,
so let's keep
the roundup upload going.
We are going to be playing everybody's
favorite game.
Know your meme featuring the one and
only shoon eyes.
That's right.
Shoe and ice is back in a big way.
Call us in at eight Oh eight hot meme.
They,
yes,
that is our real phone number and yes,
we are taking calls.
They're eight oh eight hot mean.
Ooh.
Speaking of hot,
I've been having diarrhea.
A lot of diarrhea.
Labor Day.
No hot.
Well No,
the,
the poop is hot like I northera.
Yeah.
Got It.
Yep.
Why is diarrhea hot by the way?
Like I never had a chance to let you
know.
When you bake bread,
you're supposed to let it cool and like,
yeah,
go room temp.
So that's what diarrhea is.
It's pooped that never got it.
Never got to go room temp.
But that's why it's hot under cooked.
That is the scientific poop is what
diarrhea is.
I eman happy Labor Day.
Hope you guys all had a nice break.
I had one too many hot dogs or something
cause I've been having diarrhea since
4:00
AM then really pooping my brains out.
What's the deal with Labor Day,
by the way?
TheF that fricking mailman's walking
around delivering mail yesterday.
I'm like,
oh Labor Day,
Labor Day.
Federal employees don't even get the
damn day off.
Labor Day.
What the hell?
What are we celebrating if the mailman
can't go,
you know,
take a seat.
That's weird.
I find that really very bizarre.
Just like decided to work on his own.
I don't think it works though.
Federal government,
I don't think you just pick up your mail
bag and just start passing out
envelopes.
Cheryl was a Usbs,
s u s p.
S cause there's those Amazon guy.
You know what?
I'm not sure.
I didn't see him pull man.
Oh Isaac.
Well either way it's like,
you know,
late Labor Day,
everyone who gets labor day off or like
white collar workers,
you know the real people that need labor
day off are the ones that are like
slaving away at Amazon and Mcdonald's
and all these shitty jobs.
Right.
It's just so funny.
Labor Day has turned into such as a
stupid day.
Labor Day was originally made to
celebrate unions and celebrate like
worker rights and shit and like
meanwhile you got the post man and
around envelopes.
Well that's enough about Labor Day.
The real takeaway is that diarrhea is
under cooked poop.
That make sense guys?
Let's get started.
We got a lot to talk about.
Me Royale is coming to fruition.
Ksi Versus Logan.
Paul.
Everyone was saying,
oh that's the fight of the year,
but in the century Nivea in the fight of
the year because we are in the early
stages of organizing what is going to be
known forever as meme royale 2018
because this my friends is an annual
event.
We've got people that are in so far.
Joey Salads,
prank invasion,
shoon ice there Bradbury's so flow all
squaring off hundred thousand dollars of
prizes.
I think the big,
the big fight should be prank invasion
was joey salads and then I think a great
undercard would be shooting ice.
Fourth verse Ethan Bradbury,
which be the battle of madness because
they're both a little crazy and I know
shoot nice is like over the hill so to
speak,
but he terrifies me and by the way he's
been working on,
he looks really good.
People are going to place bets like
sure,
why not?
It's loss of it.
I mean I'm not going to take bets but
somebody will,
you know,
it's crazy.
I'm sure there'll be a spread if we so
guys get excited me Maura out 2018 is
happening.
I want to see colby person getting his
hands dirty.
Is Faces too pretty whenever Jeff,
God,
coby person.
Who would you,
I would like to see koby vs like Mo
cause you know,
I was originally thinking and then they
see tv.
Oh that's a good matchup.
I originally wanted to pit Ethan
Bradbury verse Moe Bradbury,
like the the boys.
But I think,
I think Ethan would smash him.
You can't contend with the smell,
that pure madness that is behind his
eyes.
Like you even see in their videos when
Ethan's like intimidating Mo and I was
like,
damn,
he would never have a chance.
So we'd have to pit moe against someone
like Dennis.
Yeah,
that would be pretty hot.
Super excited about that.
In fact,
guys,
uh,
you may have been following the story as
it's been evolving here on this h three
podcasts,
a correct opinion episode.
We've had it up a little bit of a
altercation with prank invasion.
Who called me out to box me,
which was the,
you know,
I want to say,
how would you say the,
the breaking point for this meme right
out cause prank invasion challenged me
to a battle.
And of course that's not something that
I'm interested in doing,
seeing is that I'm a pudgy little guy
and prank invasion literally just got
out of prison for three years for some
kind of sexual crime.
Um,
that is not well,
it's literally,
well I don't know what I mean.
No,
it's,
it is a joke.
I didn't try.
It is a joke.
What I'm saying.
Do I need to say that every time?
Maybe once guys.
I do not think,
I'm not saying that it's,
I wouldn't be surprised.
Can I say that if you went to prison for
a sexual crime,
you can say that.
That's not,
that's not definitely,
I wouldn't be surprised if I want to be
surprised at all.
I'm anticipating it.
Um,
so he,
he edited this footage together of what
I said last episode and he said,
respect to h three h street productions
for admitting he's scared.
Takes a real man to admit that respect,
bro.
Now send me your address to the podcast
and I'll actually play you a quick game
for a quick kiss.
Ooh,
dude,
this guy wants to come to our podcast.
I mean,
shit is so demanding and his tweets now
quit playing.
I mean,
here's the thing,
dude.
And I send me your address.
Well,
I don't know how we,
I don't know how he,
yeah,
I'm scared of you.
That's not like,
that's not like unmanly to admit that
I'm scared of some unhinged psychopath
who serve roid it up and just got out of
prison for a sexual crime.
Like if you,
if you walked by some on unhedged
lunatic with like a hell's fire between
his eyes under his,
behind his eye is not crazy.
It'd be like,
Yo,
I'm scared.
Scared of you dude.
Um,
and not,
I mean,
and,
and it's because you're insane.
You know,
let's get it straight then.
You're not a man,
you're not a man face like I'm not.
Okay,
well anyway,
let's just watch this.
His little edit here,
bro.
You look like you've disappeared for a
year and and you were in prison and
you've been lifting weights that whole
time.
Like the last video you may have.
I was scared.
This guy was in prison for a year,
Bro.
You literally repeated me saying,
I was scared that you were in prison for
a year for a sexual crime and we're
lifting weights that whole time.
I am scared that you want to come to the
podcast and kiss me.
I'm terrified of all these things and I
openly admit it.
If that makes me less of a man that God
bless.
Okay.
I wouldn't be surprised at all if that
guy went to prison for a sexual crime
within the next couple of months.
That's not defamation.
Right.
The joke,
cause I could see some people start,
I could see some rumors starting to pile
up that Chris went to prison for a
sexual crime.
Yeah.
Chris went to prison for a sexual crime.
Mila,
it's a joke.
He didn't,
but I wouldn't be surprised.
That's all I'm saying.
Do you think I'm insane?
Do you think that's my skill that I
would get in a ring with you and fight
you?
I mean he,
he's veins were like searching.
It's like what did you do to be
imprisoned for the past two years to be
that lucky?
He sees that as a compliment.
He's like,
he thinks I'm so jackie themselves in
prison for two years.
Well at any rate,
Chris,
I would definitely like to play you for
a quick game for a quick cast.
And I think that could be a special
segment at meme royale in 2018 quick
game for a quick kiss bonus edition or
you're going to play a rock,
paper,
scissors.
Can you imagine kissing Chris?
His breath is probably so gross.
I bet you hear his tonsil stones.
I was just worried about the noise.
It's more than anything a host stay in
with people just listening to me.
You can think that I'm gonna make that
noise with Emmylou naive.
We should bring,
you know,
it would be funny,
you know how you have these a ringside
models at boxing matches.
If we brought one of these girls to do a
quick game for a quick Kessler then into
the mic,
that'd be fucking epic.
Ila seriously on down anyway,
so yes,
I am scared of you.
Good job.
Prank invasion.
You freaking ski.
You'd scare the hell out of me.
Now interestingly,
Joey Salads is on the phone.
Who was gone?
Who?
Joey has challenged prank invasion to a
fight.
I think it's going to be a really good
Did did brink frank invasion.
Acknowledged Jolie's yes.
Challenge.
It took some time.
It took some finagling,
but we have actually lined them up and I
think this is something that is going to
happen.
At first it was really hard to tell.
I had answered in response to this
fight,
Joey sells my money's on salad all day
and the thought of you getting Mommy
Makeout Dade,
buy a salad head keeps you up at night.
And then he said,
you want me to put 100,000
on it?
I said,
apps a fucking Lulea put 100,000
on it.
It goes to the winner.
Winner takes all those guys are going to
be out for blood.
It's a morale 2018 where were you when
the salads fell?
Now he's this good.
It would be a real fighting and like,
or like fake fighting.
What he was this wpf frank's fake
fighting this,
I mean $100,000
on the line till the winter.
I'm not saying one is better than the
other.
Like I mean I'm not faking shouldn't be
on you want to fake it.
I just can't believe like people will
actually hurt each other.
Well like Logan k assignment,
they're wearing gloves.
Yeah.
Well this is,
this is one again.
Joey Salads sent me this dm and I
cleared it with everybody to get the
permission to show this.
So Joe was trying to talk frank invasion
and to having fight.
And again,
this is why Brag of Asian scares the
hell out of me because this guy is so
unhinged that I wouldn't be surprised if
he went to prison for a sexual crime
within the next couple of months.
Joey said,
have you been training?
And I had a box.
So anyway,
he says,
are you going to do it?
Prank invasion says,
I'm thinking,
not boxing,
but nna no gloves cage to bare knuckle
fight.
We sign waivers and the fight last until
someone gets knocked out.
Unconscious gives up or dies.
We'll need lawyers like this guy is,
I mean I can't tell if he's serious,
but that sounds like the worst of us
have an absolute lunatic.
He said,
dude,
that's just too,
that's at least wear gloves.
I got joey's actually entertaining,
not entertaining.
Do you not watch the h three podcasts
live correct.
Opinion zone for content just as this I
asked who is entertained right now,
Joey Salads and preg vague and bare
knuckle fight to the death.
Joey Salads,
first
prank invasion cage.
Fight to the death.
We need lawyers and wave
whoever thought we would get to this
point.
But down all being said,
we've talked enough about it.
Let's see what the salad man has to say
about this.
Joey Salads,
you are on the air and are you scared?
Like I am of Prank invasion.
I am.
I'm scared for his life.
He's going to have to sign a waiver
before the spike in case I accidentally
kill off.
You think that you've got what it takes
to take out roided out prank invasion?
Yeah,
a little crazy.
You know more than a little crazy.
But how joey,
you seen his physique and his new
videos,
he's clearly disappeared and he's been
lifting weights and he's been getting a
little crazy.
Have you seen this?
I have seen it.
It doesn't frighten you?
It newbie gains.
Okay.
We just started working at La Newbie
gains and I'm joey,
you had mentioned to me,
uh,
something about him wanting to fly out
and fight you.
Is this something that you guys are
going to be doing off camera,
separate funds?
I don't think so.
It just sounds stupid.
Fight to the death.
I told them at least let's do the boxing
match first and then fight today.
Now what do you think now?
What's your take on preservation?
Joe?
Do you think he's being serious?
What has happened?
Because he's winning from Kissing
Cutie's on the boardwalk to literally
wanting to have a death match.
What has happened in the world of Prank
invasion?
Joey,
can you tell us?
You know what,
I can't tell cause I was friends with
him for like a week,
like two years ago.
I friends with him for a week and he
seemed kind of normal.
But then he was telling me he uh,
he suffered from low testosterone.
So we needed a,
the bouncer on an enhancement.
But I think he just started taking those
and that might be making a move this
down mine.
Cause I know some people,
they lose their minds when they started
taking my performance enhancing stuff.
So,
so you're dealing with science possible.
They think he's learned this
testosterone to levels that are
unstable.
Yes.
That's what I believe.
That is fascinating.
Now are you going to be able to contend
with that massive overload of male
testosterone?
Joey,
are you going to have to come around
with your own testosterone and Steroids
Brown?
I've,
I've got,
I've got my own necessity.
Softer on that should be sufficient.
And um,
you had told me an anecdote about how he
has a secret technique that he did.
He beat up a bunch of dudes on camera
reset.
He didn't want to show you the video.
Do you have my information on that?
And if you could stop washing dishes,
that would be good for the show.
You kept me on the live in 30 minutes.
I started cooking.
So now I gotta clean my daily.
You're alive when you're saying nick,
can you just,
can you hold off cooking a meal?
I mean,
Jesus,
come on man.
This is our moment here.
We,
we,
we prepared for this.
What are you cooking guy?
What are you preparing?
Hopefully it's something.
I got it.
Okay.
Hard.
I got my protein.
Yes.
I'm already trained and I got like
training and like an hour right now.
And he's doing meal prepping.
Yeah,
I got a hard boiled eggs.
I got a Turkey Patty,
sorry.
As much as I'd love to hear more.
I did ask,
but that's enough of that.
I've heard enough of your meal tech
right now.
Tell me about this video.
That creek invasion.
He says there's a secret video of him
beating up several people by himself
now.
Joey,
tell me about this video.
I would give him $1,000
cash if you would send it to me cause I
don't think it exists
cause you had asked him,
send me the video.
He said,
I don't want you to see my sacred
technique.
He said that verbatim,
which made me think that it's kind of a
kissing prank thing of like my secret
technique.
Yeah,
so it kind of sounded like,
I think maybe what he did was he tried
to get into a fight with someone and try
and kissing them and,
and then just ran away.
Very interesting.
Third technique to do.
Is there any other closing words,
any words that you have for Prank
invasion?
Anthony would like to say we'd like to
cast the gauntlet.
Any accusations and slander about him
being a sex criminal that's been in
prison for the last one.
Would you like to add before we say
goodbye and let you cook your meal there
that you're so eager to cook
is if he bails out,
I'm going to be pissed and you're going
to be a bitch because he's been kind of
flaky with this whole thing.
Trying to go from boxing to taste,
death,
nine sliding,
fighting.
He's a flaky guy.
I don't,
I can't tell if he's trolling or if he's
actually that weird.
So there's $100,000
on the line and I got to Chris.
Uh,
you know,
your channel has not been holding up
strong lately.
Lots of citations.
Um,
and I think that $100,000
is a lot of money for any man.
No matter how many girls he's kissed.
Am I right joey?
Okay,
well,
I'm excited.
Everyone is on the edge of their seat.
This is what it's all about here at the
HBCU podcast.
Joe,
we love you.
We love having you be part of the show.
You're don't forget to eat those salads.
I know that you're not a fan of salads,
but it's important to cover up.
Joey,
how do you get fiber when you're
preparing for it to be,
to be in healthy shape?
Seeing that you don't eat salads at all?
Well,
how do you get your fiber,
Joey?
Joey,
I'm f.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'm not sure,
but I'm not sure.
I'm not sure that's a sufficient,
not one to talk,
but I am also not training for the
century.
Um,
how many hours a day are you trying to
joey?
Three for three.
Four hours a day.
Wow.
That's impressive.
That's very good.
That it was a lot.
Now are you afraid that prank vision
being a little bit of a mad dude is,
might be go for a ear bite or something
of that sort?
That's what I'm worried about.
I'm going to,
I'm going to tape my ears down the ears
down.
I like that.
That's a good idea.
Better safe than sorry.
Right?
Well,
with $100,000,
you can buy yourself a new ear.
Joey,
we thank you.
We wish you all the best.
Keep training,
keeping that bread.
The fiber is important.
I recommend metamucil,
which is a great fiber supplement that
was recommended to me by a friend has
helped me out a lot and I wish you all
the very best.
Joey,
thanks for giving us a ring.
Thanks.
All right Joe had God bless you and
keep,
keep uh,
keep fighting.
All right,
you're the best.
Well there you have it,
Joey Salads in the flush.
Now just to summarize joey,
he's thinks he's going to win.
I think Joey's going to win.
He has accused prank agent of taking
testosterone which has made him kind of,
I want to say a rage filled mania hasn't
resulted in and he is,
he has called out prank of Asian and
said if you flake you're a bitch.
He said,
and I believe something else.
Something else.
We know that he's flagging cause we
tried to do it then know your meme.
And he was like right,
I'm going to do it.
And then he never responded.
Well,
I think what we need to do next is
basically draft a contract between these
two that locks them in a obligates and
basically if he,
if brank invasion backs out of the
contract,
what's going to happen is that I'm going
to be in contact with his probation
officer and we're going to make sure
that those sexual crimes he has
committed or not going to be expunged
and are going to remain on the sex
offender website for a long,
long time.
Just a joke.
But we should,
we should get a contract with,
they'll go with the guys.
Yeah,
but the thing is even with the outbreak
invasion,
we still have a great fight because
shoon ice is going to tear someone's
head off their body.
Um,
how are we doing on time?
I guess we got a little more time here.
Time.
We actually,
here's some great footage up next.
I got a lot to talk about before we
throw it to commercial.
Let's watch Ted Cruz now.
Ted Cruz.
I don't know what the situation,
here's what he's in a church of all
places playing hope and man,
Oh man,
can he throw a rock and by throw a rock,
I mean drops like a rock here.
Let's have a look.
No sound.
So here he is prep in.
He's about to take a run that's travel.
He's not dribbling and he tries to dunk
it off a trampoline and boy does he just
follow up.
No,
I mean like a bag of dirt bag that we do
that again.
Yeah,
I hear you have ted Cruz taking a
running jump at a trampoline to try to
dunk the ball at a church down the
center lane.
I don't know.
You call that a church.
The pupils,
the poeple's.
How do you,
what do you call those seats?
Pews?
The pews full.
I think they are just in prayer praying
for Ted Cruz to hit a slam dunk.
But the prayers were not answered and
he's straight the hell it looks like the
devil literally stuck them down.
You're like the Fi's grabbing dropped
basketball and a harder than gravity
allow.
I love it.
So anyway,
shout out to Ted Cruz who,
yeah,
by all accounts is hated by all,
but nobody could ever say he's a bad
basketball player.
Next up here on the podcast,
we've got three Therissa may the British
PM dancing.
Okay.
And my dude,
thank you.
Let me get with it folks.
I'm actually going to Africa and doing
this.
What the heck is that white as shit I've
ever seen in my life.
See,
I'm,
I'm conflicted.
On one hand,
I don't know if I can be like,
hey,
you know what you're making an effort
to.
Yeah.
So like,
that's admirable,
right?
Yeah,
it is fun.
I think it is.
Okay.
I mean,
that is,
that's like,
you know what it reminds me of is that
episode of Seinfeld dancing.
It's that weird.
It's weirder.
I think he's with her hands.
She's like climbing and that hair,
it's like her body is broken.
She's like climbing at the air and man,
it's like,
it's bad.
But I guess,
yeah,
Alan Ball,
the cheese out there.
I don't know anything about her,
but it makes me think,
makes me like her.
She,
there's where you're like,
yeah,
cool.
Can I have a George Bush kind of thing
where it's like,
you know,
as a person,
I don't,
I don't know anything about that either.
But here's more of her dancing.
He's getting in there
less western,
those hips.
She looks like she's hurting sheep or
somebody who's like,
right.
There you go.
What is it when you watch someone dance
that you have to like try to dance?
Remind me I'm ever in this situation.
Just smile and nod.
It's kind of a lose lose.
You can't be all right if you're just
standing there,
you're like,
Hey Paul.
Yeah,
I,
you know what?
God bless her.
Right?
You crushed it.
That one's not nearly as good as the
first one with the client.
Get the air.
The climbing move was something I'd
never seen before.
I was a freshman.
Um,
anyway,
off to good start.
Are we entertaining here?
What?
Boy?
So I guess that's been about 30 minutes,
hasn't it?
So I'll throw it to a quick commercial
break.
We got back Logan Paul verse case,
I copyrighted our highlight.
I'm going to rant about that bullshit.
We got Pewdie pie versus t series TV
series about to pass Petey Pie and sub
count.
Who the hell is t and how do they have
so many views and subscribers?
We're going to dig into that and so so,
so much more new pit bull video with a
dancing frog.
You're not going to believe this is
real.
It is guys,
you are watching the h three podcasts,
correct?
Opinion zone do not go away because my
dudes that would be wrong and here we
are right all the time.
Stay tuned.
Thank you.
Two 23 and me for sponsoring this
episode 23 and me is a DNA testing
service.
They can offer insights into your
ancestry health,
wellness and traits 23 and me health
plus ancestry services includes reports
on how your DNA can influence your
weight,
sleep quality,
caffeine intake,
sense of taste and whether you are
likely to be lactose intolerant.
Now,
in my case,
I did do 23 me and I learned a lot about
myself.
Sadly,
it doesn't help fix the things that
you've found wrong with yourself,
but it is interesting and the case of
lactose intolerance.
I find that out every morning when I
looked at the toilet that yes,
I am lactose intolerant,
but it is good to have the science to
back it up.
Now it's easy to do.
You simply spit in a tube,
which is the sexiest thing you pretty
pretty much doing the planet provided to
you and you're 23 and me kit mail it and
you mail your saliva,
which is a unique experience you're not
gonna be able to do anywhere else and
the sample get it.
They see the lab gets in,
they analyze it.
Now they,
there's a guy in the lab,
he just throws in his mouth and squashes
it around.
No,
I'm kidding.
They've got advanced at machinery that
the crunches,
the numbers there.
Now here's some things that you might
find out that my intrigue you about
yourself.
Bitter taste verse sweet and Salty.
Your DNA plays a role.
If you,
which foods you like and they're going
to tell you which one you are.
Sleep report.
Are you a deep sleeper or you a light
sleeper?
Well,
they'll,
they'll read your DNA.
They'll tell you all about it.
Pretty interesting stuff.
Oh,
that's why I never sleep.
I thought it was because I'm just
neurotic and uh,
nope.
Not My fault.
There you go.
Feel better already.
Um,
saturated faster verse wait,
report tells you based on genetics how
your weight might affected by saturated
fats in your diet x.
There you go.
Don't feel bad anymore.
Yeah,
I'm a fat cow.
Oh,
it's in my DNA.
Can't do anything about it.
Sorry,
Sam.
Sorry.
Lela,
uh,
offered tea.
That's true.
It gave you,
I'm telling you this is,
there's a lot of interesting stuff in
here that you're going to learn about
yourself and the world around you.
Okay?
Uh,
here's what you need to do to get
started and spit in a cup a tube.
If you were order,
you're 23 and me healthplus ancestry
service kit at 23 and me.com/age
three.
That's two,
three and me.com/h
three.
I'm telling you,
it's so fun.
It's so interesting.
Treat yourself and see what's going on
in those jeans because,
uh,
there's much more than meets the eye.
The genes.
Did you look in your genes?
I don't know.
What else is there to say about quip
electric toothbrush.
Okay.
It's the greatest toothbrush on the
planet earth and take it from a guy
who's obsessed with oral hygiene.
It's got it all.
Let me recap for you,
and I've got something else to add.
The Brussel soft enough to not harm your
gums from enough to give your teeth a
squeaky clean.
It's got it all it vibrates.
Do we have that will come to h two h
three Acmr.
That's right.
It vibrates and it tells you when to
switch sides.
It tells you when you're done brushing.
It's a three minute timer.
It make sure that you,
because your mom doesn't live with you
anymore and you have to take care of
yourself,
are done brushing your teeth.
Here's the part that blows me away.
There's always something new on the back
of it.
It's got this hard rubber stop.
You know what?
That's for Ila clean.
You're the gun that the tongue is a
tongue scraper and it works brilliantly.
It's got it all in this tiny little
tube.
You guys,
I cannot stress it enough.
Try it out.
You're gonna love it.
It's incredible.
Guys,
here's the offer from quip.
If you don't have it now,
what are you waiting for?
I mean seriously,
quip starts at just $25 okay?
If you try to get an electric tooth
brush of a caliber,
you're going to be dropping $200 on some
coal gate.
More like Watergate,
cause it's such a scam when you buy a
colgate.
Am I right Ila?
Yeah.
That's how I feel.
Quip starts at 25 bucks.
Go to get quip.com/h
three right now and you'll get your
first refill pack free with the quip
electric toothbrush,
the refill pack,
you pop this off and a new brush head
lands right on there.
God dammit.
That's your first refill.
Pack free at [inaudible] Dot com slash
[inaudible] spelled g t q u I p.com/h
three try it out.
You're going to love it and everyone
around you is going to love it even more
because your breath stinks.
Thank you.
To seek gig.
Okay?
If you're looking to go to a live show
and event,
a sporting event,
whatever it is,
that it's got tickets,
they've got you covered.
Now let me tell you about seeking,
okay?
You get a view from the seat.
Whoa,
right off the bat,
superior to the other ones.
Oh my God.
Am I sitting in front of a giant pole?
I can't see anything.
No.
You see the seat,
you know exactly what you get.
They rate it on a scale of one to 10
green is good,
red is bad,
so you know if you're getting a good
deal or not right out the gate.
Boom.
It's simple as that.
They know what they're doing.
Okay?
Now I've established that it's a great
platform for buying tickets.
Seek Geek,
but here's where shit just gets crazy,
okay?
Because they want you to come try their
APP.
They have got this offer for our
listeners that's out of this world.
Use Code h three h three when you
download their app with the Lincoln
description and you get straight up $20
off your first order,
oh,
that's just them handing you a $20 bill.
This is a deal that you don't see coming
around very often.
They just want you to try it out and
they've got 20 bucks on it just for you
to come see.
I mean,
they're just hosting the tickets.
They're literally giving you 20 bucks
off your ticket price.
I mean,
that's insane.
So click the me tab on the APP and enter
code h three h three for $20 off your
first purchase.
You got the link and description to
download the APP.
Guys,
it's as simple as that.
Give them a shot.
I think they're great and they're giving
you 20 bucks is to put their money where
their Dang mountains are.
So head on over to seek you.
I love him.
I appreciate it,
and I,
and God bless him as well,
and God bless you.
And the $20 you're going to be saving
with seatgeek.
Welcome back from the break guys.
Uh,
today we've got a special presentation
put together of know your meme,
featuring the one and only shoot ice.
We've got a caller on the line here.
Let's get started.
So,
uh,
let's say it on two G.
Gee.
Oh,
you're welcome to though.
[inaudible] Joe,
how are you doing today?
You have a fantastic,
even better now I'm talking to my
favorite couple on youtube.
Oh,
thank you joe.
You're too kind too kind.
Do you know?
Nice.
I get ready to win a Samsung Galaxy as
by blah.
Okay.
Oh hell yeah.
Let's do that.
Alright.
I,
you've met Shu and I said before,
tell me about that interaction if you
yeah,
so,
uh,
it was 2011,
I was a freshman at State University of
New York at Albany,
uh,
and Mr Shoe.
Nice.
Kind of hijack a,
the cancellation of one of the biggest
student events by changing himself to a
fountain in the middle of our campus.
Uh,
he wear diapers to go to the bathroom
and he didn't eat for,
oh,
it was probably at least four or five
days.
Now.
Can you tell me why?
Wow.
So the biggest party of the year at that
school is a,
it was fountain day when they were
turned on the fountain in the spring.
Everybody would go in and it's a good
giant pool party.
But for Saint Patrick's day,
there's another,
uh,
unsanctioned event called the kegs in
eggs,
uh,
which is just basically everybody wakes
up at eight o'clock in the morning and
starts drinking.
Uh,
so long story short,
a few police cars were flipped over.
People were on top of cars playing
bagpipes,
real shit show.
Um,
so they ended up actually canceling the
Fountain Day Event and Shoe Nights,
uh,
who claim to be a student,
tandem stuff to the fountain.
And nobody really at that time kind of
knew who he was.
I don't even know if he had the
following.
Now I'm going to be had the following
now,
but
I am slightly confused.
His,
he protesting the event or the
cancellation of the event,
the cancellation of the event,
he,
uh,
he claimed to be a student would shove
with a little bit interesting because
you can sell you the most of the
students.
So you said he changed himself and he
shit himself in a diaper and fasted for
four to five days.
What did he achieve a success in his
hunger strike?
No,
I think he was actually forcibly removed
it.
Oh,
probably,
but we did not have mountain day that
year.
Uh,
he tried,
but did you leave?
Did you have the opportunity to meet
this great man and talk with them and
say,
shoe,
tell me about what you're doing.
Can I smell it?
Your diaper.
Okay.
Nobody really knew that he was the guy.
He didn't tampons on Youtube.
Some warrior,
you know,
fighting for the little did they know
that just came up there.
He was chained up there in his giant
gear.
Just,
you know,
screaming at anybody who walked by.
He got all the local press to pay
attention to them.
Um,
that's
visited him once or twice.
That story
definitely lines up with the shoe.
Nice.
We all know and love.
No problem.
Stretching my imagination to believe.
Yeah.
Joe,
we've got you here.
We are ready to go
play.
Let's just get right the F intuit and
start with the first question.
So Lube up,
get ready.
Shotgun.
A bottle of alcohol.
Let's start with question one.
Joe Is the weirdest thing shooting and
ice has eaten.
Is it a,
a bottle of k,
y Jelly,
anal.
Lou Anal,
not normal.
Vaginal.
There is a distinction.
I want you to be aware of being tampon
soaked and hot sauce joe or see a bar of
deodorant.
The choice is yours,
Joe.
Oh Shit.
The weirdest.
That's objective.
That is hit and his opinion,
this is in his
opinion.
Well you,
your job is not to seek truth.
Joe.
I remind you,
it is to get into the mind of the shoe
himself.
That what size is that shoe and does
your head fit into it?
That's the strip.
We are running out of time.
You have 20 seconds.
Joe.
I pumped and Pantheon was blood,
but I'm going to say the deodorant.
See the weirdest thing shooting ice has
ever eaten.
See Deodorant.
This is really anticlimactic,
but I don't have the folder open with
that answers.
Just uh,
just everyone chilled back.
I ever ate was probably a tube of k.
Why Jelly?
Anal lubricant close first with three
tampons dipped in a hot dog.
Joe,
I have to say I'm somewhat disappointed
that a bar of deodorant sat next to anal
lube and a tampon soaked in hot sauce.
They found the deodorant feed the least
bizarre or the most bizarre,
the three of those.
But that just shows what a decent kind
hearted a man you are.
Now I remind you,
the objective is to get into the shoe
itself.
So going forward,
we got more questions.
You know,
we've got to get into the shoe,
Joey with us.
Alright.
I gotta get more depraved.
Let's do it.
Yeah,
you've got to get into this shoe.
So here we go.
Question number two.
That's fine.
We've got plenty more to go.
What did she nice tell ilow that
prompted her to tweet this.
Isla said to him,
slam some more toilet paper to clean the
shit that's becoming out of your mouth.
What provoked this from Ula?
A shoot.
And I told her her clothing line sucks.
B,
he called her and Israeli whore or see,
he said he wanted to eat our dog
shredder.
Joe,
enter the shoe.
That's the one I know he called you the
Israeli horror and I'm so sorry.
That's horrible.
And you're sweet.
You're a sweet,
sweet man.
Joe,
we appreciate the,
uh,
the sympathy.
So let's go to the,
uh,
answer books itself.
Be called her and Israeli horror.
Gotta be a little more slick and prompt
these up Mara.
Time.
There we go.
This is real fucking this up.
Okay.
Well what happened is I was my drinking
days,
I've been sober since last Christmas.
He by the enemy had talked down an email
and I was heading out to California and
Nathan's like,
it would be great for us to get
together.
And I emailed Ethan a few more times and
it came up,
you know,
he wouldn't reply to me and I was just
like,
well can you let me know within the day?
And then I uh,
I was just on twitter and I'm a ball
buster,
so I just,
you know,
I said,
hey,
you left,
you know you're a Jewish whore.
And I mean,
no,
I'm sorry,
you're an hour from Israel.
That's what I said.
If she was from Tennessee,
do would have been a horror from
Tennessee.
But yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not ready.
I wanted to take that back so bad.
I mean,
I was literally,
I don't even remember typing it to be
honest.
Wow.
Joe,
you are correct in this point,
but I actually,
I want to correct the record.
[inaudible] was shooting ice.
What happened,
I think was that
he wanted to come on the podcast and he
had emailed me and it was like so
tentative.
He was like,
Hey,
I'm coming through La.
Uh,
maybe I'll pop in and we can do a
podcast or something.
And I was like,
I was like,
sure,
I'll let,
I'll let you know something like that.
Then he think about it or sometimes not.
And then he emailed me like 20 times and
weirded me out and I was like,
oh,
fucking shoe.
And Isis were crazy.
I didn't get lucky,
dude.
I hadn't yet learned to harness that
power.
It scared me,
but I did.
I needed to learn to harness the power
of his star as Thor's hammer does.
Um,
so then he just went railing on us one,
nine twitter.
That being said,
Joe,
you were correct.
You are on the board.
The one,
we're all very excited.
How are you feeling?
You feeling good?
Feeling confident?
Oh hell yeah.
We'll do it.
Samsung Galaxy s nine plus with a retail
valuable $1,000
terrific phone and use it myself.
Pretty excited for you joe.
So here we go.
Let's stupid on to question number
three.
Now this one is a toughie.
How many youtube accounts does nice hat.
Now you may have seen in our previous
episode of the Tuesday edition that shoe
and ice left so many comments on our
video.
It was heights of and Sandy,
I've not known on Youtube until now.
So I asked you this,
Joe.
Is it a nine youtube accounts?
Is it be 29 youtube accounts or is it
see Joseph 50 Youtube accounts?
Enter the mind of shoe and tell me what
is your answer?
Go big or go home.
See.
Ooh,
wow.
Well Joe,
you are entering the mine of shoe and I
like to see that you've,
what you've dropped all rationale or
reason.
You have put your head in the shoe and
Joe,
I love it.
Let's hear the answer.
That is a lot to coordinate.
I don't remember the thing.
That's hard.
You too.
Youtube accounts.
I think that gives you,
but they have all history.
They have subscribers,
videos on them.
They're really not goes to accounts.
They all have his literary and
interaction.
I use them exactly how I got um,
Capcom and on Ethan's video I'll post
the comment and then switch to another
county and it'll just list them.
So well I'm doing is just taking switch
accounts,
another channel bouncing in,
liking,
commenting.
But it sounds crazy,
but yeah,
that's all me.
It does sound crazy.
Well,
you're right about that and joe,
you are right.
That's totally fucking bonkers.
The chant that much free time.
The Youtube accounts study switches.
Wow.
She Nice.
I'm telling you,
this guy is a legend.
I think he is going to be the first
official member of the goof troop.
The goof game.
What do we like?
Goof troop or goof gang.
Goof gang is more of an alliteration.
Joe,
what do you think?
Yeah,
do squad goon squad a partial to Gath
gath pack.
I mean,
why can't it be all of those names?
Well we've got a brand,
you know,
we've got a brand at appropriately.
You got to leave it up to the people.
Yeah.
Oh Damn.
Let's do a poll right now as we speak.
We have the power,
we've got twitter.
So we've got goof gang,
we've got goof troop,
goof troop.
That's kind of,
I like goof troop and then what we'll do
squat.
You what had you suggested a a young
Joseph.
Good squad.
But now I'm like in years a little
better.
Well let's add it but it shouldn't,
I couldn't pollute the full,
let's add it for the sake of historical
preservation preserving Aaron's
definitely.
And uh,
then I don't want to,
did you have one you wanted to add?
Anyone else?
I said Gaf pack back or I'll throw it up
there but the throw that poll up there,
Dan and
keep us updated.
Um,
that's on our twitter by the way at h
three podcasts if you guys want to
participate.
But I have a feeling that shoe nice
himself is going to be like a true like
founding medic member of this
organization because he's special.
If you'd be Asian beetle juice.
He is.
He's my beetle juice.
I can't really think so.
Like,
like I,
I,
I love him.
I think he's got so much potential,
you know,
Super Nice.
Doesn't Evander's 10 how's,
how surreal this whole experiences,
cause we used to watch this video.
It's like deodorant,
bars all my life.
Actually.
I had some videos.
I want it to watch.
You want to watch some videos.
Joe A,
you're on the scoreboard.
You're two to one maybe would help you
to enter the mind of shoe.
I want to show you guys a video.
Um,
and some are march.
This is actually from his New v because
he started so many channels.
He's such a Weirdo.
He erases all the footage on his old
videos all the time.
And then he makes a channel called Schuh
nice deleted videos.
So erases it on one channel.
We're,
he uploads it on another and it's just,
I don't,
he's just on another level.
So He's into asm.
I don't know what sparked,
do nice of all people again to Asmr.
But he has this character,
Marge Simpson Asm Mar.
And this video was just from um,
oh it's from the turn of the year.
I said the end of 2017 but here is a
little glimpse of shoe and ice.
Marge Simpson,
a smr,
and this is completely sincere.
This is not some kind of a bizarre,
surreal humor.
This issue,
and I was doing March Simpson,
Asmr.
Hey everyone.
Shoot ice asm are,
he's whispering.
That's why it's so quiet.
I didn't realize how many people were
affected physically and emotionally by
my asm are.
Hmm.
Either way,
he's basically just sounds the same.
You just have to turn the volume up.
Crack,
right.
That's what smr is.
Oh,
we need is the voice from shoe not been
watching my ace in my own team.
One to 100 open that by the time I get
to honor,
he'll be asleep.
Either way,
we have the special asm.
Our guest here today,
she would like to say the alphabet and a
few words.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Marge Simpson.
Oh my God.
Do you see that mark just walked in
for anyone who's willing to try the
alpha?
Nope.
Yeah.
Hey.
Oh my God.
Nige in waking up to this sound.
Imagine the middle of the night,
fall asleep.
Did this sounded not quite sure what's
asm are about the uh,
you,
so this is what we're dealing with here.
Okay.
All right.
You guys,
you guys have seen enough so joe wants
more tonight Joe.
Yeah,
exactly.
Joe,
will you be watching that to help you
sleep tonight?
Absolutely not.
All right.
I hear you.
Uh,
that's being said.
You are on the scoreboard to till one.
Joe,
we applaud you are excited for you.
We think you're great and we think of
all the potential in the world.
Let's move it on to question four.
This is basically a few when this,
um,
you get it all.
This is it.
Well,
right now the last question,
the last question,
but if he wants this,
he gets the Dang phone.
Yeah.
So that being said,
Joe,
are you ready to play
Papa blocks?
Yes.
So yeah.
Okay.
Here we go.
How many times or has shoe nice ever had
alcohol poisoning?
For those of you that know
no shoe,
nice,
famously takes a whole bottle of booze,
puts it upside down and no hands and
drinks it straight down to throw in like
a second.
He's done it with handles.
Okay.
So has she denies ever had alcohol
poisoning?
Joe?
That is the question at hand.
Hey,
never,
not once
b one time or c seven times.
Huh?
So tough one.
Joe,
what do you think?
What do,
what do you,
what are you feeling?
I wouldn't be never so good guys.
Keep it up.
I mean,
shooting ice is definitely the kind of
guy that would never have ever had
alcohol poisoning.
It's a great guest.
But is it correct?
Well,
Joe,
let's find out.
Okay.
I passed out with the dabbles springs
one 60 proof.
I wasn't dead.
I just go to bed.
But I happen to have friends over at the
time and they couldn't wake me up.
So they brought me to the hospital.
I'm a veteran,
so my insurance is free.
I didn't care.
But I woke up with a tube down my
throat.
They're pumping my stomach and I was
just like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Are you going to kill my buzz?
Well,
Joe turns out it was one time and the
doctors killed his bus instead of
killing him.
But uh,
you,
you were wrong.
But that is fine,
Joe,
because you're doing great.
You're on the board.
It's two two.
This is exciting.
This is good for us.
I like the,
I have and the cliffhanger is terrific,
but this one is,
I don't think he'll have any problem if
you're shooting ice fan.
So let's just pop right into the fifth
question.
Joe.
How does shoe nice show gratitude.
Thank you bea.
Thank Ya.
Or See.
Thank you very much.
Can I defer,
differentiate does enough.
Do you get good?
You catch me?
Uh,
do you catch my drift on that?
Joe,
do you have,
uh,
do you,
did you understand the question?
Could you repeat the answer
please?
Thank you.
A thank yeah.
B,
thank you very much.
Seen.
Thank you.
Now that's a,
yeah.
Oh,
all right.
Are you rehearsing or your answer?
All right.
Thank you very much.
Just restating.
MMM.
Okay.
Thank yeah,
thank yeah.
All right,
Joe,
liking where your head's at and I'm
feeling pretty good about this branded
food.
I usually say,
yeah,
there you go.
Yeah,
it did it,
it was a close call.
You know,
it was three to two.
You pulled it out at the very end
though.
How are you feeling?
Oh,
sandboxing taxi.
Just talking to you guys is like a trip.
I love you guys so much.
Thank you.
Yeah,
we did thank you.
Shout out to Sean Evans for showing so
many like great people on hot ones and
get egg like I've found so much that
threw him down.
You guys,
all your,
all your guests are amazing.
It's like I find none I found killed
Tony.
It's unbelievable.
I'll tell him much.
They're going to be a guest on our show
soon.
Yeah,
but thank you.
Can't wait for that.
We love you as well.
Thank you guys.
Stay on the line.
I'm going to get your info so we can
send this to you.
Right.
So Joe was a pleasure to talk to you.
I wish you all the very best.
And um,
thank you so much for listening this
galaxy phone plus.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
All right,
talk to you.
Thank you.
So that was great.
That was awesome.
Um,
now there is one bonus question left.
Isla do you want to play?
Yeah.
Do you have the answer?
Well let's just play.
Let's just play then.
The second question is what's the first
thing he ate on Youtube?
So here you guys go.
My first dog was a roll of toilet paper.
Single ply double apply or fog up the
system.
Yeah.
So we finally found someone that likes
single ply
toilet paper.
So that's why they make it just for
shooting ice.
Well guys,
that was another successful edition of
know your meme.
Congratulations to Gel and is getting
Samsung Galaxy s nine plus.
Yeah.
Um,
what else we got to talk about,
man?
I mean that's,
I don't mean,
I mean that's the best shit.
Now we have a lot more to talk about.
Um,
let's see what's next?
Logan.
Paul.
These fucking guys.
Okay.
Logan Paul Verse Ksi,
the promoters,
whoever's involved in this shit is such
dicks.
Now we talked about this and we made a
highlight of it,
which was like 20 minutes long and
okay.
I barely,
she,
I didn't even show footage because I
knew that they are going to be dicks
about it.
Yeah.
We don't even show him show.
It was one,
two is compilation of Jake Paul getting
punched in the face.
And that was like,
what's your,
by the way,
has intrinsic artistic value that that
is the legal language be real.
So for them to fucking block at
worldwide,
you stupid ass holes.
And here's the best part.
I disputed.
I'm like,
hey fuck boys.
Hey,
Hey idiots,
eh,
you know,
release the claim
and they can keep it down for 30 days.
Youtube gives them 30 days to just sit
on that and keep it down.
Like the video should go up.
If I just viewed it,
the video should go back up.
I mean that's just,
it's,
it's crazy.
And they're such assholes too,
by the way.
Ksi video is just down for 30 days.
Remove.
Yeah.
And then at 30 days then he'd be like,
Oh,
you're right.
Sorry.
It's back up and nobody wants to watch
it anymore.
Yeah.
But like,
you know,
Ksi and Logan Paul,
okay.
Sorry.
Specifically is a guy that reacts to
videos all the time on it.
Yeah.
No,
I mean this is honestly just sad.
And I know this has been happening to a
lot of people and it's just,
it's,
and you know,
you know what really pisses me off about
it is like before the fight,
they feed on everybody's publicity and
everybody's talking about and before the
fight fair use.
Oh Great.
Yeah.
Talk about it all you want after the
fight.
Talk for 22 minutes and don't even
fucking show the footage.
And we're going to block a worldwide.
I swear to God there's a case for like a
class action lawsuit because it's so
abusive.
I mean they haven't,
no,
no exploited.
They have no right to remove it.
It's just,
that's what I said.
I said don't.
I said you have absolutely no right to
block.
That's just how the tools work so they
can,
well,
I think youtube needs to modify the
systems that you dispute it.
Okay.
Now the videos back up and now if you
want to strike my video,
if you want to put your money where your
mouth is and make a legal claim,
then go right ahead.
Okay.
It's so frustrating,
man.
And for me it's not,
it's not that big of a deal because it's
just one highlight of a lot.
But like,
yeah,
I mean it had 300,000
views and like half a day,
but if that's your main content and they
can just stomp on you like that,
it's just fucked up.
I Dunno man.
Not Happy about that.
That really pissed me off and they're
intentionally just sit it going to sit
on it for 30 days because they want
people to go buy the paper view.
That's so stupid and it doesn't really
make sense.
No one is going to watch our highlight
instead of that.
Well there was no capitation.
Exactly.
If anything is going to make people want
to go watch.
Yeah.
That's the whole thing.
And that I've never understood about
most copyright copyright issues where
it's like almost every time except for
pure re upload yeah.
Is going to result in more traffic into
your original product.
It's just so pathetic.
So I want Ksi and Logan Paul both to
know and I'm sure both of them will
easily be like,
uh Oh,
that's just a,
that's just our production company.
You know,
if they do,
first of all bullshit.
I'm not letting you get a pass on that.
Look at this shit.
They,
they make it under this like Shell,
the shell company at t h piracy.
There's no information,
there's no accountability.
It's just this,
I mean this is Ksi and Logan,
Paul and all these guys getting around
having to take responsibility for doing
something shitty that they know is wrong
on youtube.
A T h piracy.
Give me a fucking break.
The real crime is,
look at that film now.
So good.
The world deserves that.
I agree.
I love that thumbnail.
Good.
Dan,
that was you,
Dan.
By the way,
your copyright dispute is currently
being reviewed by the copyright owner.
You'll receive response within 30 days.
How about three days?
How about they have 24 hours and then
the video goes back up and they can
decide in 30 days.
Why are you on the Dick of abusers?
Youtube like it's time to do this
differently.
They have been improving though.
Well,
I think you had to have been less
aggressive.
Like we had this video on anything
Daniella,
where we react to this lady like dancing
to hip hop and it was apparently
attempted to be removed by Youtube,
said no.
So they'll send you an email saying this
was,
there was an attempt about,
we said,
no,
actually I have to give huge credit to
that department.
That used to never happen that,
that's actually happened several times
where we got an email being like,
and the best part is they say who tried
to take it down.
It's for some reason when someone tries
to take it down and they rejected,
I see their email,
their phone number,
their name,
the channel.
I get their social security number
basically.
No,
and they're like,
this idiot at this address tried to
remove your video and we gave him the
middle finger.
But somehow when these assholes do it,
it's a total fucking shot in the dark.
You know it's not,
it's just,
I honestly want to blame these guys
because they know what they're doing and
whoever put this together,
no day there.
You tubers,
Dane know how it works.
They're willfully abusing the systems
that youtube has put in place that
generally work pretty well most of the
time and it's just,
it's so late.
Especially Ksi because he does react to
videos.
He relies on other people's content.
Yeah,
the Paul brothers,
you can't expect anything from them
ever.
Nope.
You guys know the law better than most
because of the lawsuit that you went
through and everything.
The whole 30 day thing,
is that youtube policy or is that the,
is that the actual legal law,
like the DMC a thing?
Oh,
that's just youtube.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm 99% sure.
That's just completely unrelated to the
law week.
I mean youtube put their policies in
place originally.
Basically they were faced with a huge
decision when they were in their infancy
and people were pirating content all the
time and putting it on youtube.
And so they had an existential crisis
where they needed to deal with this
issue or get sued into oblivion and not
be a legitimate platform.
Yeah.
And so they are very legitimate and they
do have a pretty good suicide.
I'm like,
if you compare it to facebook,
there was no system at all.
Yeah.
So Youtube is pretty good.
It's just,
it's hard to deal with so many people
and it was always going to be someone
who will abuse it.
It is,
I mean,
this video in particular,
it's just so frustrating because I
didn't even show the footage.
Yeah.
We were just talking.
I literally explicitly avoided showing
the footage because I want it to avoid
this.
And now 30 days and I'm help,
I can do nothing.
It's just so f up.
It's so whacked,
Dude.
It's seriously so wack.
So you know,
fuck these guys.
I Dunno.
Hey,
speaking of whack,
got a 3000 responses on this Paul
already.
Oh yeah.
Give us the information.
Well,
I got to tell you,
we are deadlocked at 33% each between
two it goof troop,
both 33% trailing a little behind his
gaf pack at 27 and then port group
squad.
Nobody.
Nobody's on board with goon squad.
What are the,
what are the top two again?
Can you uh,
day and goof troop.
They are gang goof troop.
I think.
I personally think the goof game because
of that generation.
It's just going to say that I would put
for that one goof gang.
Let me vote right now.
He has got to tip the scale.
Okay,
that's interesting though.
Anyway,
Pewdie Pie.
Here's another one.
This one Pewdie Pie as everyone knows,
has been the biggest subscribed channel
on youtube for pretty much ever as far
as I can and common history and what
he's up to like 65 million subscribers
now,
but out of nowhere comes this channel t
series.
They're out like 60 million subscribers
and their channel is going insane and
I'm thinking,
who,
who are these guys?
What is t series?
And so that is what I'm here to answer
for all you guys today.
What is t series first,
let's start by looking at their stats.
Okay,
let's pull up the social blades here for
TV series.
Now past 30 days,
2.1
and a half billion
views.
Yeah,
I saw that number and I,
I was like,
wait,
there's too many numbers.
They call us too many digits.
Uh,
in the past 30 days they've had 4.3
million subscribers,
a plus bus.
The grade 4.3
million in the last 30 days.
Their parents would be proud.
I mean,
compare that with Cutie Pie.
Let's see.
Damn,
like Cutie Pie has 150 million views.
So it's a lot.
He's about,
uh,
I mean,
what did,
what did they have like 3 billion and
not a comma and he's under a million.
So they're on a,
on subs per month,
which of course is nothing to scoff at,
but they are on track quickly.
The past young Felix here and so fun
ended.
There's a grade,
there's a lot of double plus a plus.
Oh yeah,
they're breaking the metrics here.
So 2.1
billion views,
that is just madness.
So,
okay,
who the hell are they and why are they
getting so many fricking subscribers and
views t series?
Well,
the answer should
hm
not surprise you.
I don't know what these big challenges
are always so weird.
It's just an,
it's like Bollywood Shit.
It's just a bunch of Bollywood Shit.
And you know,
I was looking at the population of
India.
These motherfuckers have like 1.4
billion people in India is there about
the past China as the most populous
country.
So they are churning out youtube views
and unprecedented numbers.
If I was Indian I'd be crushing it,
getting 10 million views a day.
Um,
so anyway,
I curated some of their videos to show
you guys what's going on with t series
here.
Let me show you first the channel.
Yeah,
it was,
let's look at the channel.
No,
they upload a ungodly amount here.
10 hours,
600,000
views,
nine hours,
20,000.
So the variance is quite large.
You know,
one day,
100,000
views and then you go down a little bit
and you can see.
So the views are pretty paltry.
But then here you see five days ago,
20 million views.
Hmm,
excuse me,
I'm allergic to views.
And so then you keep going through here
and you see this little nuggets like,
oh six days ago,
11 million views.
Yeah know one week ago,
10 million views.
So these guys are just shitting out so
much bollywood that it's giving my wood
Bali,
I'm getting a Bali hard on right now
looking at these numbers,
right.
How is it possible the channel like,
like,
cause if it's the,
if the views vary so much,
why do people subscribe?
You know,
usually those kind of channels of will
not have subscribers because they just
kind of like,
the truth is you let,
and you're,
and you're right,
it will be a viral video,
but mostly not.
You know,
the truth is that is correct because if
you look at the ratio,
they have over 2 billion views a month
and they're getting 3 million
subscribers.
I think puty pies viewed a subscriber
ratio is way higher,
but he's getting like 20 or 30 less
views per month,
you know?
But there's the scope of uses and
seeing,
it's like everybody in India,
I've got the hard lined in t series,
so let's watch some of their greatest
hits.
It's curated India's finest Bollywood
here for you guys.
And let's see what these guys are up to
shelly
and what do we got here?
Most popular video.
Uh,
whoa.
Look at the view.
Almost 600 million views.
How old are they?
Do they just,
this is only a couple of months old are,
well,
several months old.
Let's have a look.
Cause they're like,
they're viga.
Is it there?
What?
Vivo?
It's like Indian Vivo.
That's right.
Now this,
this Bollywood is the cornea shit on
the,
on the history of the earth.
I don't think anything has ever been
produced corner than Bollywood.
Here's a guy.
Uh,
he's texting while driving and he almost
plows down,
cut short.
The lives of two sweet,
innocent young girls.
Do they react poorly and say,
hey,
I'm calling the police.
Fuck you know,
a seduction happens from this.
Of course.
Okay.
He's on his phone.
It's not lenny almost murders and cold
manslaughter.
He saw it.
He's like,
Hey,
what's up girl?
I almost fucking killed you.
Huh?
So anyway,
Yada,
Yada Yada.
Hollywood guys,
by the way,
to or like the corniest mother dude in
here anyway.
Fuck at the end of the day,
you know how it goes.
Um,
thought that was interesting.
We've got more to come.
This was one of their most recent
uploads,
which was quite violent if I can say
that.
Um,
see this is they're low viewed ones.
This one has 26,000
views and it was just uploaded today
actually incidentally today,
I'm only four hours ago actually.
So who knows?
It could be their next big hit.
It's very violent and um,
quite shocking to be frank.
Not Noticing Bollywood action movies
that these Bollywood Stars somehow
always looked like janitors or something
like this is the cause of action star.
And I guess their,
their idea of masculinity is just,
it's very different from our own,
it's interesting.
A lot of Kung Fu movies,
the guys aren't necessarily like
handsome leading man.
Either they look back and this guy
doesn't look bad at,
at least in my opinion.
But Hey,
in India he might be king fucking dog.
Uh,
I really don't know what's happening.
So an execution,
there's really not much preload to this
either.
Just lots of execution and bullet time.
And now this janitor is about to kick
ass
Jesus.
I see what you mean.
She's gotten like a bad vibe.
I mean he like even if you put them in a
gooey and made them look as bad as
possible,
he would still just look like,
you know the kiosk,
the guy,
the Kiehl's.
So he grabbed it as a regular guy.
Dick slammed him.
We've had the,
the,
that hat,
what kind of name that died.
Here are now daddy.
Wait.
But at that hero and my opinion needs
like there needs to be something that
back up the fact that he can kill 20
guys with his bare hands because the
Pudgy guy at the kiosk,
I'm not necessarily believe in it.
She's got a big heart.
He's got a big heart and he sliced to do
it in half and suddenly and a hand right
off,
man,
this is violent.
So there you go.
And I don't know what I mean,
this is just nonsense.
It's crime.
Sorry.
Beauty.
Fine.
So this is actually really violent.
I'm not going to show it,
but he just executes that guy.
Well I really don't know what I just
watched the essence of Bollywood.
Yeah.
Always because maybe those are clips
from a movie and they like turn it into
a,
you know,
an action set piece thing for youtube
can it's bollywood year.
Overthink things.
Not a bollywood.
I got a sack and uh,
that's some good stuff.
All right.
No,
I listen.
Well you got another video.
I am not trying to slam bollywood.
Okay.
Make 'em I'm goofing around,
you know,
let me step back a minute.
It's just the Indian sense of culture
and entertainment and masculinity and
femininity and all these things are so
different.
It's just an interesting thing to be
hold and art.
All Indians,
the goofiest people you've ever met in
your life.
No,
I'm kidding.
That was a joke.
I was stepping back and then plowing
forward.
Isla thought about it.
She's like,
cause I was like,
Hey,
no,
I was going to say they are actually
very nice.
The ones that I knew goofy though.
Okay.
Maybe I'm kidding about it.
I don't actually think that,
come on.
This is the history,
podcasts,
opinion zone,
right?
You entered,
everyone enters.
Not everyone leaves a what else we got
here?
I guess that's about it.
You get the idea.
Here's another one.
This one is 210 million views in less
than one month.
There you go.
They just,
they have so many hits.
I mean that here you go.
More Dad's beating each other up.
[inaudible] this is a real one of these.
We joking about it before the shell.
What is it with all exotic like non
European cultures.
They all do.
What's this?
They do it in Israel.
Isla you've fucking got a crazy one.
DNA and Israel and Middle East.
Even in Greece they do this and uh,
Lebanon,
he,
Ron and now I'm seeing even in India
we're doing this.
Why can't white people get on this?
You just can't pull it off.
Like everyone in the world's doing this.
You know what I mean?
Ethan,
you're such a,
yeah,
you're what?
What's the criticism of me right now?
I Dunno.
Such a bigot.
They get no criticism.
There's one opinion here and it's
correct.
Begging Ethan.
So closed minded.
Ethan is so disrespectful of other
people's cultures.
Yeah.
Well
give me one of these.
Give me one of these in fucking,
you know,
go subscribe to two series veer.
So multicultural.
Why you go subscribe to t series with
notifications on already did.
Anyway,
I thought it was interesting if you guys
are glued to the TV about this rivalry.
There is of course a live counter up to
five earth years t series,
live stream,
live updates with music and everything
you need to be entertained.
Let's take a look at the numbers.
Wow.
We've got pewdie pie in the rise t
series is catching up quick.
Oh I give them like a day.
Yeah,
they're,
they're going to creep up really fast.
So that's out there.
If you really have nothing better to do
with you.
Ah,
what else?
Hmm.
Hit poll came out with a new video.
That is truly something I couldn't
believe Israel.
This is why I showed up to work today.
We've talked about pit bull here on the
podcast with Jack and Eric and man,
this new one,
I couldn't believe.
I can't believe what I'm seeing is this
frog.
Like I see the frog here.
So I guess it's a reoccurring meme.
You see this healer?
This says 800 million views.
Oh,
they want to got missing something.
Let me watch this.
This says 800 million views.
She has a dancing frog.
It's so weird.
What the fuck?
Look at it.
800 million views.
That's almost a billion views.
That is not related to this song.
So yeah guys,
this is 800 million views.
El Chapo ultra music.
Could you do this possibly to this music
or the Latins on this?
I don't think so.
They're more salsa.
It's like a mixed with then submitted
through any,
this frog is on a ease on Mars cause I
ain't ever damn,
this shit is so weird.
The 800 million people watch this.
Who made this and why it's good shit.
This quality content.
Oh,
why is the whole world so weird?
Like,
okay,
Latin America now it's on my goofy list.
I wonder what is it in America that
white people do that everyone else,
like those motherfuckers are weird
apparently.
Shit without a buddy day based off of
the responses we've gotten.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean all the emails that I've been
seeing,
people wipe their ass,
hold their hand.
I think that's probably not totally
Ian.
Look,
there's someone to look that up because
I don't want to be that ignorant to get
that wrong.
Well maybe some,
I mean there's 1.3
billion people in India,
you know?
Hmm.
Um,
well yeah,
I know there was something that we're
all fat probably.
They're like,
well,
you're all fat and you don't talk about
that all the time.
It's,
yeah,
that's pretty,
that's a big one.
That's kind of big.
Morbidly obese is pretty wild and it's
just like being overly polite maybe.
But is that the same thing as 800
million people watching a dancing frog?
I'm not sure that's on the logo.
Like,
here's this video.
Get my needles,
your boy dancing frog tape on.
Got The funniest face I've ever seen in
my life.
Dude.
He just fucking the frog.
Just strip naked.
Hell you guys.
It looks like the girls want to fuck the
frog.
If I'm being honest,
there's,
there's not really irony here.
Like they're serious about this frog.
Do you think flux better to the frog or
a pit bull?
I think they think it's funny and think
so.
They're not like that.
Frog is bad ass.
Thanks.
So Isla,
who would you rather fuck?
Pit Bull or the frog.
I gotta go with the fraud.
I'm going to have pit bull feels about
that.
Although you're not alone.
All those girls seem to want to fuck
frog.
I'm being frank with you.
He's got crazy hip thrusts that frog.
He can really shake it.
It looks like
salad fingers.
I mean it's just not human.
It's just not right now.
No
frog.
Oh my God.
Close your eyes and don't say a word.
All right.
I'm seeing enough of that frog.
Whoa.
I really wonder what white people do
that words the rest of the world out.
Yeah.
Um,
what else?
We got this one.
It kind of feel like I'm being so
ignorant this episode,
but I got a plow on it.
Doesn't get better from here guys.
We're ending the meaning of it down.
It took a seat.
What does it mean?
Maybe you should read this.
Where,
where is it located?
Where are you reading it?
And it is located on the Google.
I do help me out and I on all right.
Dom,
add to Casita means,
um,
casino,
right?
Sita.
It means,
and it's got a picture of the frog den.
So I know I'm right.
It means,
um,
stay still and be quiet.
And this will all be over soon.
No,
it kind of means give me your little
thing.
Whoa.
That's even weirder than what I said
though.
The literal translation of the word
Caseta is an innocent enough.
It means little thing.
The course of this duty is dripping with
sexual innuendo and Latin America.
Dom a Tuco Sita means give me your
reproductive part.
Whoa.
This frog is Grazie don to Casita.
Holy Shit.
Give me your little part.
Oh,
sorry.
Doesn't really translate.
That's what they're saying.
They're saying in Latin America that
means give me a reproductive,
I think with like the implication,
I think it makes like give it,
give it,
give it to me babe.
Yeah.
I think that frog has got more planned
than,
you know,
done.
Um,
okay.
Let's move it on.
You guys know about this test holiday.
She's a plus model.
Now I want to handle this story as
tactfully and our fleet as I can't
because I feel like I have something I,
a legitimate thing that I want to
express about this.
Okay.
I don't know what that was and I don't
want him to be,
you know,
I want to handle this,
uh,
you know,
politically here.
Okay.
Now we've got tess holiday and she's
featured on the cover of cosmopolitan.
She's a plus size model.
Plainly,
you can see that it's extremely plain to
see [inaudible].
And,
um,
and so this whole thing about like,
you know,
they're trying to normalize and say
like,
Hey,
you don't have to be and shape or
supermodel right to be on the cover of
cosmopolitan or to be an object of
beauty and admiration.
Right.
It's like a healthy at every size kind
of thing.
Yeah.
And,
and when I saw this,
I was like,
you know,
if you're going to criticize magazines
for putting anorexic girls on the cover,
which promotes an unhealthy lifestyle,
I don't see that this is any different.
When you put a morbidly obese person on
a magazine and glorify it,
that's just as unhealthy as anorexia.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not saying she's not beautiful or
that someone would not be attracted to
her,
but like I don't understand this
argument of saying somebody is fit and
attractive and work super hard on their
health and their fitness.
By the way,
I have so much respect for people that
actually maintain their physical body
because rich or poor or wherever you
are,
you have to put in the work.
There's no shortcuts.
There's no work around whoever you are
from the king to the peasant.
And if you want that body,
it takes raw work and dedication.
Now this does not require that there's
no,
there's nothing in my mind,
commendable.
There's nothing and my,
and I'm not,
and I'm not saying fuck her because
she's fat.
That's not my point is,
but that we look at someone who is
physically fit,
that they have achieved something and
that's why we admire them and we put
them on magazines because everybody has
the potential within them to carve their
body out of marble,
so to speak.
You know,
to chisel away through hard work,
that perfect body.
But this,
there's no,
there's nothing admirable.
I mean there's,
there's no,
uh,
achievement.
There's no
hard work and sacrifice and it's just
the conversation took a weird turn.
I can,
instead of saying you don't,
you can feel eh,
confident,
you know,
you can,
you don't have to feel horrible about
yourself.
Yeah.
And be apply size,
but you don't need to glorify it.
I find it bizarre.
I find it frankly bizarre to glorify.
I mean,
a more morbid illness.
we sat here and talked with Boogie who
was morbidly obese.
I mean the guy is not,
there's nothing good about being
morbidly obese.
And if you feel good and happy with
yourself,
God bless.
But like these are the same people.
They're saying,
oh,
these anorexic models are not realistic.
Yeah.
They're not realistic.
They're models.
It takes a lot of hard work.
The look that good physically to get a
six pack and have a fucking crazy ass
and thighs and be like fit beautiful
person.
Right?
Yeah.
It's not realistic.
It's really hard to do that.
Hmm.
So,
um,
I think this is weird.
I think it's weird.
I don't get it.
And by the way,
also I just want to point out to,
people always talk about like photoshop
and like,
oh,
that's not realistic.
It's photoshop.
She is photoshops all the way those
thighs and her chest and her arms and
everything.
Her face is so photoshop.
Then I have to tell you my hunch is that
that unedited video,
that unedited photo,
you would look at it and be like,
that lady's sick.
Not Disgusting.
But I mean like you see what Morbid
obesity looks like.
They've paint brushed it and brushed it
and made it look beautiful and
attractive and hey she's got soft skin
and she looks good and she's got tattoos
and shit.
She has a little miss piggy on her form.
Incidentally.
I didn't say that.
I mean it's right there Mr [inaudible].
It's on her forearm.
The treatment of the photo is the same
as the ones they're criticizing anyone
cause she's still got makeup.
She's exactly,
it was photoshop.
You can see exactly the shading and
everything is on.
It must have been touched,
you know,
in Photoshop.
And by the way,
I've met a lot of morbidly obese people.
I'm a fat guy and obviously to that
level.
But boogie was saying like think
morbidly obese.
It's a,
it is like an illness as I understand
it,
but like there's nothing happy about
that.
[inaudible] I dunno.
I Dunno.
I don't,
I just don't,
I don't get it.
I think as dangerous.
I think we as a society need to stop
being like,
I guess I just don't know what's the
point.
I mean like I wear over the point where
we're like,
you're fat and shame on you and
whatever,
but like to put someone up who's sick
and say look there,
to glorify it in the same way,
it just seems hypocritical.
Yeah.
This was a tough one to talk about.
Their hailing her as a brave.
I mean,
what's brave about,
you know,
eating ice cream?
Did I go too far?
I don't know.
Can I get one of these?
Uh,
was waiting for a joke?
Yeah,
I said nothing.
You know what does bother me though is
on the other hand,
let's get our shit straight.
Okay.
Like we've got this shit on,
but the re I think the real damaging
shit that's going in magazines right now
is these Kim Kardashians.
Okay.
With fake asses,
perform through dangerous procedures.
See that is unobtainable.
So then you've got these glow,
these poor girls who are working their
ass off to try to obtain an ass like Kim
Kardashians,
which is actually literally impossible.
Now that is an unrealistic goal to set.
I mean here,
let me,
let me show you these Kim Kardashians.
Before and after these,
these,
these Kardashians are fucking twisted.
It,
they've had so much surgery,
like there's nothing left of like who
they used to be and it is.
So I feel like it's so damaging for
actually for young women who are
comparing themselves.
Look at this.
This is going to fucking crack you up.
Look at that ass before and after.
Yeah.
It's like she just excuse,
you've got to like whoopee cushions in r
and so I gave him the picture on the
right is not updated anymore.
It's gotten bigger,
progressively bigger.
I Dunno,
her ass has gotten so fricking big.
Look at this one.
I mean,
get the hell Outta here with this.
Which one do you want to say?
Um,
just there's like a dress there in the
middle.
Yes.
Anyway,
that's all of them have these like
bodies that were created laboratories.
I mean,
if you want to talk about some of these
unhealthy,
that's what's up now actually,
I have a story here about,
and it's really sad.
Um,
what are we going to say?
You do something bad?
No,
this lady went to get a bum lift as they
call it,
a mother of three.
It was told by her partner,
she did not need surgery,
but obsessed with these images of Kim
Kardashians.
All these woman with fake acid,
which is one of the strangest phenomenon
is I would say maybe that's what Indian
people think is weird about white people
and we'll get an ass surgeries.
No,
everyone's doing it now.
Thanks.
So [inaudible] um,
and it's not only white,
but get a load of this.
Uh,
Leah Cambridge,
a 29 year old beautician from Leeds in
England is said to have died this week
after she underwent the increasingly
popular cosmetic surgery at a clinic.
Was it in Turkey or somewhere?
Yeah,
the guy was apparently a world renowned
surgeon.
And what they do is they take the fat
from your other parts of your body.
Yeah.
And they inject it into your ass.
But the catch is that it's actually
extremely dangerous because what
happened in this case is that he
injected the fat into one of her main
arteries that went through her ass,
and it went to our heart and our brain
and she had a fucking stroke.
Okay.
Yeah.
So how about that for ridiculous,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I dunno.
I feel like we should be talking about
this mental illness that's in our
society.
People are putting fat in their ass.
Yeah.
Um,
crazy shit.
Good.
Yeah.
Even Cardi B has a story about how she
did and in like a surgery at any illegal
place just in some lady's basement.
I mean,
that's probably,
people can't afford to go to probably
the legitimate places,
the procedure costs.
Um,
oh,
she,
she definitely want cheap.
Okay.
The procedure costs 6,500
pounds to 10,000
pounds in the UK,
but in the Turkey it costs 3000 pounds.
Well,
I didn't,
I was probably expensive and Turkey,
but like,
man,
God,
that's so tragic.
Like Jesus Christ.
I think we need to be talking about
that.
I think guys who talk more to their
girlfriends and tell them they really
don't need to do it well,
because I feel like it becomes like a
competition.
But when women and they start to feel
insecure next to that,
the article said the guy told her she
didn't get it.
Like,
well what could he do?
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's so bad I think.
But it's like you open instagram and all
you see is like this crazy but like
unrealistic actually unreal sick bodies.
We used to consider unrealistic bodies
in this dialogue of like super fit,
hardworking people that achieved a god
like body.
Yeah.
Now we're talking about people that are
injecting fat in their ass and then
little girls have being like,
how do I get that ass?
Oh,
I'm gonna go get fat injected in my
heart and have a stroke.
Well,
yeah,
it's really easy.
It's really easy to feel insecure when
you see all those acids.
[inaudible] Graham is very dangerous.
I'm,
I'm very,
I'm skinny and like Brady flat all
around.
And it's like when you look at those,
all the instagram models these days,
it's crazy.
It's like,
do you feel bad when you see that stuff?
I'm pretty at peace with my body so I
don't,
but I can see,
I can point in your life when you were,
yeah,
there was when I was younger,
but I think I've,
I've talked to our friends.
Perfect.
Just leave.
But I know and you're asked to flop.
You're asked is great.
Everything's going on there.
It's a very regular too skinny person.
The dips,
a great one.
One of the best.
But like,
yeah,
I've talked to,
I do have friends and I know people feel
pretty insecure and a lot of people are
doing the surgeries and a lot,
let's talk about not reach people to
ethical morning.
Let's talk about that.
Yeah.
I don't know this whole thing about
like,
I feel like,
and it's the same in Israel,
so that's why I'm saying it's not,
I don't think it's only here.
So that was a whole discussion about
body issues.
So I hope that there was something
there.
Interesting for you.
And if you're considering I'm injecting
fat into your ass,
don't do it.
Please.
I frankly,
I on my part,
when I see Kim Kardashians ass,
I'm like,
you have a disease.
It looks like you have a tumor in your
ass.
It just becomes like a,
almost like a carrie could.
Sure.
It's looks,
it looks like,
I mean to me it looks really bad.
How did she,
when she shits it must be like a long
way to the toilet.
It was that got a lot of space between
the ass you cause it's so big she must
have to like either she's spreads open
the ass cheeks super wide or she's
getting shit streaks on the inside of
her cheek and did not think about that.
Think about it.
Also these days you have to have like a
10 inch Dick just to get inside of her.
Wouldn't you love to discuss with her
her wiping?
You've got Kim condition on the line?
Yeah.
I'm not sure that's a conversation she's
uh,
she's ready to have.
No.
But seriously,
like how do you even have sex with a
girl that fat?
Like the barrier for entry is like eight
matrix plus it works like that.
I think the fat goes like sideways and
more all up to the side.
I mean that doesn't sound sexy ladies.
Keep your ass natural.
Keep it all natural.
Okay.
You're looking good,
you're beautiful.
And I guarantee you there's Min,
every,
everywhere,
every corner you turn that wants to fuck
you.
It just the way you are.
And most of them don't even have a tech
big enough to penetrate the ass on Kim
Kardashians.
Right.
You'll okay.
All right.
What else?
We got not pep talk.
Louis C.
Case back.
Woo.
I feel like I don't want to talk about
this.
Not because I,
I'll talk about briefly just in Somas
there's so much here,
but we see case back.
Um,
he just popped in apparently.
You know,
it was funny cause we were talking with
Bert like,
yeah,
before this happened and we were like,
um,
Louie,
he was going to be back at his opening
line is going to be like some genius
line.
Yeah.
And everyone's gonna be like,
oh,
he's a genius.
And he's back and we said like,
we don't know how long it's gonna take.
And like maybe two years,
couple of years,
and then the next day.
You know what I got to say?
A lot of people were upset that he had
the balls to come back and that he
hadn't been punished and that,
you know,
Fuck Louis C K,
that's not my angle.
I think he came back too soon.
What I what I'm disappointed in as him
as a comedian,
you can't just come back on stage and do
material like a,
nothing happened.
He didn't even address it.
Like I did hear the material was funny.
Wow.
Yeah.
I'm sure he is very funny.
But it's like,
dude,
you had the moment.
The moment had to be perfect.
Yeah.
He had to come out after a couple of
years and when people almost forgot it
and be like,
so how about them dog years?
Huh?
Or whatever.
I know.
So it was way too soon.
Just people need enough time to like,
yeah,
it was too thin.
They just the news.
But then someone had a good point.
Was it?
I don't remember who brought it up.
Was it Dan?
Uh,
can someone take shredder out?
He's got your hurt.
Treader it's his birthday and all.
He's such a cutie pie cook them a
flaming neon.
Okay.
We said it was shredded birthday at the
top,
right?
Yeah.
We're going to cook them a Philemon
Yellen tonight.
I'm most excited for me to eat a flaming
on.
Um,
I just think,
oh,
I forget who said this,
but they're like,
he's probably so depressed and
borderline,
even suicidal.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but like,
yeah,
that,
that was me saying that and yeah.
And you know,
it makes me wonder a lot of these
comedians that you guys have even talked
to you on the show.
Just talk about how like therapeutic
even for you,
Ethan,
you know,
when you come and do the podcast and
everything and you know,
Louie,
his life,
his stand up.
So yeah.
Makes me wonder.
It's like I,
I agree that I think it's way too soon
for him to come back,
but I almost wonder if he was just
sitting at home alone and like,
I gotta get out there and do this,
or I don't know what I'm going to do,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't know.
His situation is a tough one.
It was just mostly weird to just not
even acknowledge.
Yeah,
that's what I,
that's what I'm disappointed because I
don't know,
there was so much pressure on that
opening line of like,
Oh shit,
Louise back.
I feel like he should have waited until
everyone almost forgot it.
Even that me too was a thing like it was
settled.
You're like,
okay,
you too.
You too.
And then wait another year and then
Louie,
his opening line would be something like
that.
Yeah.
Anyone want to see my deck right close
to the north.
Anyone in here want to see me
masturbate.
Right.
You own it to Saint Louis.
That would have been a great opening
line.
What did not have got out there and just
whipped it out.
Yeah.
Don't even,
he goes like this,
lock the doors and then he takes his
dick out.
That would have killed.
So anyway,
that's my 2 cents on that.
Guys.
This is the correct opinion zone.
You wash these Tuesday episodes for my
opinion,
which are correct and relevant.
Every top,
if you disagree,
keep watching.
I don't want to lose you as a viewer,
but just know that you are wrong.
Um,
the celeb hacker who hacked a Jennifer
Lawrence and all the celebrities who got
all their nudies leaked out into the
world,
the fat burning as it were,
has pleaded guilty.
Admitting that,
and here's what shocked me about this
story.
He sent emails to the victims while
posing as members of onlines,
apple's online security personnel in
order to obtain their username and
passwords.
This,
this amazing hacker that got all these
nudes.
He was just doing a phishing scam.
It's all it takes.
I thought this was some like slick
underground,
crazy hacker.
Yeah.
He's just a guy who sent the email to
Jennifer Lawrence and said,
hey,
please log into your apple account.
I almost feel like that is what happen
is like 90% of the time.
Yeah.
Like how often did they actually have
your password?
Oh I thought it was some crazy thing
cause he,
he had like dozens of of celebrity nudes
and
you know,
it was just a fricking phishing scam.
So there you go.
Get inspired you guys.
I think this is an inspiring twist on
this story to everyone out there who's
like,
I want to see Jennifer Lawrence nude.
But I mean,
I'll know,
you know I'm saying like,
I'm not saying that specifically,
but like anything is possible.
Sometimes you will go to jail.
Yeah,
you will go to jail.
Obviously there's consequences,
but that's not the more,
the moral,
the story is not to steal people's
nudes,
but that anything is possible.
Did you think that you could see
Jennifer Lawrence nude by simply sending
her a login credentials and saying,
Hey,
I'm from apple.
Can you log in now?
I'm not saying to do that,
but I'm just saying get inspired because
this guy had a simple idea that he took
all the way to prison and I'm saying it,
it's inspiring in a weird twist away.
You should never had done that.
Shame on him.
You know,
privacy matters.
Uh,
they should,
they should have never come out and I
should have never looked at them.
But that being said,
get inspired.
I think if you look into getting
inspired,
you should subscribe to tc or is
plugging into theory.
They need all the help.
They can get bumped.
Everything.
I'm not enough subscribers.
I feel awful for those slip that that
was a huge violence.
I want to make clear that I was a huge
violation and,
and uh,
a real,
a real wacky shame,
you know?
But Hey,
there's something inspiring there
though.
You have to admit,
nope.
Just a little piece of shit that was
going to,
you know what?
You know what he did?
It's like that movie,
the pursuit of happiness with will smith
where he had like the Rubik's cube and
that got him the job.
It's like the simple plan,
get you all the way and that's what's
inspiring and went on and to follow
along.
Okay,
let's move on.
Thank you.
Move waiting for that.
Uh,
up next.
God,
this is going on and on.
We have a lot more here.
Good.
Kind of exhausted.
I wonder if we should move some of this
over.
We could skip.
We've got Ariana groped.
We've got,
uh,
Michael Coen starts to go fuck me and
that.
We're going to go to that one.
Hmm.
Love that story.
Well,
they're already under groped is pretty
amazing too.
All right,
let's just finish it up.
Arriana groped.
So,
oh man.
Ariana Grande Day is at the funeral of a
wreath,
the Franklin and this slimy,
slimy dude,
man.
Gropes her alive during a funeral.
It's crazy shit ever.
It reminds me of this clip.
We watched him w Lou Walsh grabbing that
girl's ass on TV.
It's like they have a secret society
where they're like,
I'm going to,
they're like,
hey,
they like push the boundary with each
other.
You know what I mean?
I'm going to grow up a famous person and
what are they going to say?
It's not even about the famous person
there.
They're not there anymore because it's,
yeah,
but there's a sick mind.
It's like they're daring each other to
get away with the
stunt.
Oh yeah.
But I'm sure he did.
I don't look at it like that.
I just think it's,
it's just like what is going on in your
head?
So here it is anyway,
because
I have to brush up my pants under her.
But when I saw out the on the program,
I thought that this is a new something
at Taco Bell.
Meanwhile,
saying that he thought she was a Taco
Bell Item,
Aka a snack,
and
the most thing that he's doing with his
hand is something stolen.
Unnatural.
Enjoy this icon here.
Yeah,
he's like digging in here.
I've got a gift so you can look at more
closely.
But I like how he's saying on one hand I
grow.
I got to give you all your restraint.
Now give me that titty.
Oh goodness.
Look how he's like,
he's like really grabbing,
I mean that's intentional.
As it gets.
Right.
I mean,
there's no way to explain it any other
way,
right?
No,
it's like this and he's like digging in,
you know?
Yeah.
That's so creepy.
Okay,
good to see these men of God lately are
not winning.
The hearts and minds are not winning my
heart and mind.
I guess that's all there is to that one.
Yeah.
He apologize.
Whatever.
Um,
oh,
can you just get away with an apology
though?
Well,
the church just like want to get rid of
that guy immediately.
Well,
here's what I don't understand.
It was really half assed too.
Maybe you can find it.
I thought I had it here.
Can you guys find it?
Sure.
He's just like,
you know,
uh,
I guess maybe I pushed it.
I was hugging everyone anyway.
I apologize.
It was basically just that
said,
it would never be my intention to touch
any woman's breasts.
I don't know.
I guess I put my arm around her.
Maybe I crossed the border.
Maybe I was too friendly or familiar.
But again,
I apologize.
Here we've got a video of it.
Okay.
Bishop Ellis.
By the way,
let's just say his name for the record.
I apologize because
I have to brush up.
My 20 year old daughter tells me,
dad,
you are old and 16
fan
girl.
Did they give you all your respect?
I certainly want to apologize to Ariana
and to her fans and to our family and to
entire community.
If what I say said was taken on the
wrong way,
and Alyssa,
oh,
he's talking about the Taco bell comment
to the tick groping,
yet he's got a lot to answer for.
Maybe it's just
a joke that went bad,
but when you're doing the program for
nine hours,
you know and tried to keep it lively,
you're trying to make some funny
references and what have you.
I love everybody.
Everybody that knows the visibility and
greater reason than those that we love
everybody and listen,
it's not about whether I meant or didn't
mean it,
but whether somebody took it the wrong
way,
I'm the one that said it and if it was
taken up to be an offensive statement,
I apologize.
That's the easiest thing for me to do,
the right thing for me to do.
And I certainly hope that she would
forgive me.
And the last thing you want to do is to
be a distraction.
Didn't address the Franklin meaning of
soul.
This is all about her.
It's not about me.
And I'm so sorry if I inserted myself in
a way that took away from this.
So I apologize Ariana and to her
community,
he never addressed the tick grab.
He addressed the top of Bell Rondae.
Uh,
comment.
All right,
well the thing is I've only seen it and
like a clip of it that I thought was in
reference,
but I watched the whole thing.
He didn't even address the fricking tit
dig.
The thing is when you grab a lady here,
I don't know if she was wearing a wire
bra,
but first of all there's a wire that's
so obvious,
but even if not like this motion here is
really like he was getting sexual
gratification from that.
Are you trying to massage her tit and
turn her on?
I mean,
what are you trying to do?
Or is it just a weird,
creepy old world power play of being
like,
I can do this and get away with it?
You know,
so weird as shit.
Yeah.
Hopefully this guy's gone,
man.
I'm sick of these fucking holy men.
Like anyway,
anything else to add to that?
You'll
nope.
That's due to get like grow up like that
on live TV during a funeral.
I'm like,
she can't say anything.
She was recoiling from it.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Those situations,
you can't really say anything.
It's just really,
because it's not that bad.
It's just like right on the line.
The cribs zone.
Yeah.
It's like why you got to be such a
creep.
Yeah.
Okay.
And finally a tragic story to end the
episode.
Uh,
poor Michael Cohen.
you know,
the sad,
unfortunate Michael Cohen,
trump's attorney that has flipped on
him,
uh,
to work with the FBI,
um,
has started a go fund me to help pay his
legal fees and I'm,
we're just all so very heartbroken over
this.
Dan,
can you cue the music please?
Um,
to help set the mood?
crickets.
We have crickets,
Dan
family.
I wouldn't say it's off.
Mike Schraeder pooped.
Okay.
He pooped in the office.
Yeah,
I'm calling to birthday.
That was the only reason we're uh,
we're let him get away with it or you
know,
hopefully our office manager didn't see
this.
Um,
so I apologize.
Are we talking about Michael Cohen?
Yeah,
we're boy.
we're talking about boy.
Um
Huh.
Um,
yeah,
we wanted some sad music.
5% went to say I'm sorry.
Shredder.
I feel bad for Port Frederick.
Alright.
Michael Cohen,
truth fund on July 2nd,
2018,
Michael Cohen declared his independence
from Donald Trump and his commitment to
tell the truth and not because he was
strong armed by the FBI to avoid
criminal charges against himself.
Michael Cohen made the decision to take
a legal responsibility and continuous
commitment to tell the truth.
Michael decided to put his family and
his country first.
Now Michael Need your financial help.
Michael Cohen.
Yes.
Who in 2015 reportedly purchased a $58
million apartment building in New York's
upper east side.
Needs your help desperately it on over
to go fund me.com/hq
j u p j slash Michael.
Slash Colon.
Slash.
Truth.
Fun.
Yes.
The same Michael Cohen had a salary from
Donald Trump of $1 million a year as in
desperate,
desperate need of your help to fight the
truth.
Now that he is on the line for crimes
against the FBI.
Yes.
Michael Cohen,
sad,
unfortunate truth teller,
and we all support him in his hour of
need and we threw up that url on the
lower third.
Yes.
You guys sleeves had on you won't go
fund me.
Yes.
The same Michael Cohen,
who at one point was worth over a
hundred million dollars thanks to his
ownership stake in more than 200 New
York City taxi medallions.
Oh my heart breaks for the sad,
courageous,
brave men who was put the truth telling
first when he was faced with prison time
from the FBI.
Yes.
He's a brave,
daring man.
He needs all the help we can get.
So please head on over to Michael
Cohen's go fund me@cueatgofundme.com
slash HQ j j that's Michael Dash o dash
truth.
Just fun.
Yes,
look at that face.
He needs all the help he can get folks,
this honorable man with a net worth of
$100 million,
he's at 170,000
after out of half a million guys,
we need to pay his legal fees now
because if we don't,
then the FBI is going to lock him up for
crimes he committed and he won't be able
to.
Uh,
you won't be able to tell the truth any
longer folks.
And with that I say we're pretty much
done.
So guys,
you can keep it going.
I was enjoying that.
I don't know.
It started over.
So guys,
in the spirit of Michael Colin,
the spirit of telling truth and
spreading justice in this planet,
in this earth,
and I know you're not worth 100 million,
you don't make $1 million a year like my
colon,
but you could spare a buck.
And so remember to join us a week from
today.
Bill Barr is going to be our best.
The great the one are full.
The funny.
There will be no episode,
no episode based Thursday.
Yes,
we are going to Canada.
We are taking a moment.
Our mobile game is coming out this
Thursday.
Stay tuned for that,
but enough about us.
I'm going to be talking a bit bill burr
about hopefully sending up a truth fund
for Michael Cohen.
Bill burr flies helicopters.
He can afford to give this guy 10 bucks.
I actually should ask bill about this.
I'm curious what this tape.
So thank you all for tuning in.
I hope you have a terrific one of
wonderful week ahead.
Shredder a shit on the floor.
I need to address that.
There's a clean up properly.
Thank you Dan for handling that.
Hmm.
Congratulations to Joe on the shoe and
ice and to all of you at home who really
got educated today and this h three
correct opinion.
So Isla,
do you have anything to add?
No.
Are you feeling sad for Michael Cohen?
Really Sad.
Do you have money to donate to Michael
Cohen?
Really Ila,
not even a dollar a dollar.
Can Save this child's life.
It's cold blooded.
No,
I hope y'all are more generous than you
will.
Thank you guys and we will see you next
time.
Thank you to Michael Kahn for sponsoring
this episode.
Thanks for watching.